[music]
to
contain contact and we did
in English and showed how they
use laziness and just talked about the
problems of learning languages ​​and and the right
paddock and we decided but we need to do it in
other languages ​​and 1 non-English is
Russian the most important language in the world  yes of
course every language is a holiday every language is
precious i think if konstantin
[music]
continues something something is wrong with the
connection so let's see how well you
can hear me yes great thank you steve
thanks for this opportunity i decided to
offer to
invite three you can say my
students
probably  people who
didn’t tell which one about the link
which I showed how and how to use
this alexey this is dasha and here should be
sasha they are very different languages ​​alexey
for example and learns english but in general
now he’s more food
and even more interesting if we tell the
flow to finish swedish  I’m trying to learn this
rcp from Dasha, an absolutely amazing
story, because the person
who has whose native language is t  now
upstairs rather english and russian
monastic as soon as
she joins us she also has an interesting
story she recently moved to
los angeles from ukraine and she is learning
english they all do from
churning great well i think more likely
other people will even listen and therefore
why not, it would be better for me, it seems to me that he is
now higher in Russian, you need better
pavlovsk, as you say to many,
well then you can page
Russian bleak, and how will we
do this in the case of our English
conversation, the participants have a communication problem,
only I have, only I hear
Steve badly  intermittently i
can also have a favorite book claw
adequate decoding steve i
listen
well and you don’t
have me in case in case our english
but the conversation is there and each participant
will show how she or he uses and the
idea is somewhere to find good
youtube content sometimes there is an application  like
which helps us tell me to lose
from youtube with nickname like sources
good other possible  but it will be if
something starts but or show or
questions well import
van is not my strongest side
so maybe someone will start well
let me go I can go to or
castle if you want you can
tell you more experience in this matter
because I'm the main sources that
I used to import, well, exactly how
interesting the content is, this ted is sites
where they present a lot of interesting
material, it's easy enough to
copy both the text and the audio track,
that is, it's not a problem so
yes, well, there is of course a more complicated way
when it's just captured  sound when
playing about subtitles copied
sites all this is then uploaded poured
well actually it’s not difficult either but 80
percent of my content
consisted of books after all because this is the
easiest and most affordable way to find
an audiobook find text for it and
use it on the market now
well  now I use different sources
to find materials, but when I started,
the main ones were  audiobooks and you were here
I liked the fact that there is a fairly
large base for choosing interesting topics
there you can find quite a lot of
native speakers from the United States directly,
but since I studied American
English, it actually
started very well for me and then
further of course  we went on more complex
material, I was looking for the possibility of how to shoot
sound from TV shows, sound tracks and so
on, but
at the first stage it was not
necessary, but I think that it may be
interesting for some who do not
know about the existence of our women, I, I, I
can provide there I  I will sincerely
you see my covers yes well there we
usually see Lexington link there in this
case it is Russian but it doesn't matter
there there is a lot of things studied
well there you see there you can according to
what if you can take I already
have lived before and here  you
see it, yes, and when you have an extension
from any website automatically or
an article or videos with subtitles, this is
boo  det import on lind and youtube
have very good it means there is
time stop the mean if you be
for example when i study i dont know
turkish rare i start and it is very
for me to listen this in turkish it is
very difficult but if i do it in  kind of a
maxim because youtube has a time
stand i can only listen to this down
subtitles and because of youtube i think that
for those who are already tired of our
content on in our library and
want to look for something more interesting well,
you have to get used to using
it  formed than to import
content to your taste i don't know
konstantin odessa highway than my ears are
very a bit complicated because
i never slide russian you understand
me perfectly you excellent russian
porcelain i must say if i can steve what
if you watch other videos steve
almost every new day  gives
interviews in another language and it is not surprising
that at some point you need more blood in
Russian, which is quite difficult to achieve in
in general, everything is clear, I think that
most of us use this
google chrome extension and others, I
personally use it all the time and just
love this is the reason why I'm a
fan, but yes, so
I hear, for example, I like to
use the chrome extension to
import from YouTube
and  I like to read Wikipedia with the help of an
extension, that is, for example, at some
point I decided that each of us
watches something on Wikipedia every day, we
constantly google something and on Wikipedia I
decided for myself that I would no longer
do it in Russian  not in english
i will google and only wikipedia
in italian
i am learning italian and gradually i got used to
no longer use wikipedia not
russian and english and news
sometimes when i read news i look for
italian news to import immediately
i think that it is of course there are many
way to import  but the extension
is how easy it is to use what I
do when for example I layer on I don’t know
journalists coffee cups after cleaning for example
and  when I read something on cleaning
but maybe up to 35 percent of the words
that I don’t know but all that I will
import
because I want to see this 5 percent
and even words that I think I know
but when I see the video again and  these words
I want to see again sm here to
update her so I think that yes there are
many ways to import but the extension is
how simple what I use in but
every day in different languages ​​maybe
then Dasha will say yes what are you saying that
this is not that strong side  maybe for
you it's not so easy for me it was
not so easy the whole technological part
for me it's not just I see that I
gradually became
water dust I use mainly
safari and for safari and the extension didn't work
very well
roughly speaking didn't work and I
downloaded firefox
but I'm so not used to
using it that most of the materials
I agree with steve that you can
download everything and when I use firefox
then I remember downloading all this
and I sometimes  Yes, dedicated to
downloading materials and then I download
some kind of film or interview and it is
very important for me that the context is
interesting for me then it promotes the
gradualness of the series and then I download
often I just copy the text and even if
I use for example safari and then I
listen separately  Yes, I listen there, for example,
songs or something else in the link and then I
use YouTube or a phone to
listen, often I will upload texts and audio
from me there on audible or
here, but I also think that if I get used to
using firefox everything will be much
easier for me, but  at the same time, now I’ve
kind of expanded my reading
horizons
and, so to speak, I should understand, and
now, as if
I’m learning German, my level is
still quite enough, I just started reading everything,
too, even if there are few words or a
lot of words that I don’t know and  what is
surprising is that reading, as you
say, is always the place where you
feel very, very, so to speak secu
comfortable but comfortable yes safe
without  it's dangerous and when you start talking
instead of out of comfort and that's why I
actually love now more and more but I see
that there is boxing here because of which it does
n't work for me just
ask or the strongman had problems
because in addition to this it works it
should work  i don’t understand it
stretched it doesn’t work i didn’t
use firefox niv safari i can’t
say it modest katrina works
so please pass please and
small you and i think we can
solve this problem steve problem i
forgot well i didn’t imagine actually it is
sasha who  moved only recently to
los angeles and sasha actively began to learn
english and she is already reading her what
book do you read the
sixth sixth book before
but i had when now you read
now hunger games
but i even say when i heard that
daria is reading if i’m true  I understand these
pour and you listen for example adobe.com
or separately I also do it because
it is very difficult to import an audiobook thing
.  it is impossible to separate it by sight
it is this and i always use
one box i am looking for where the god of the game also
exists and god and for the gamepad and
pour it i work i read and
i save words and phrases and then i
listen on my iphone when i walk  when
I'm in the car it
's two separate, say, abs application,
but it's connected because
when I listen,
but very often I don't understand what I listen
to, so I want to read and then listen again,
but this is not necessary of course if we are in
links audio books and books like this is
our dream to work editions to
offer so integration of audio books
books but now it is not so
the fastest way is to import and
god and then buy and I think about good and
god it's one month for a month it's worth
pay 200 dollars or rubles and
others have some question or or
comment because
other people serve us and they I think it will be
interesting to know how we
use use and ask for a link and
because I think that we use  r and maybe
the novice market hears us, I don’t
know if you have some kind of habit at the end of the day,
which you can show in a nutshell,
I can say well, I’ve been using the link for
probably 5 years, I still couldn’t
remember when I started, but  you suppose
somewhere around five years and during this time
it is clear that some specific work process has already been developed
, well, let's say,
for example, in the morning I always have
free time and I work with new
words, that is, I have it now, as it were, a
mandatory exercise, a run, and then
I work with new words,
usually it takes even if I have
15 minutes, I work with cards up to
from the new text and I definitely
work through at least some minimum of
words, and so in general, every day it's
very fast, well, you get used to it
audio  Kostya taught me to dry from an iPhone,
meaning the audio tracks to the text
that I uploaded to the link and then, as it were,
when there is any convenient time when we
walk and be sure to ask  I listen to
those texts that I’m reading now, well, now
I’m already in, well, let’s say it’s much easier for me, it’s all
given than when it was at the beginning, when I
just started to study, this listening
was there cyclic, I took some
fragments of books and listened to them
several times, I read
it, I tried to remember now-  then everything
happens much easier and, of course, the
most important point for beginners is to
use only the content that
you are interested in and that you
enjoy learning without this,
that is, you will
face the same problem as, for example, at
school or in any other place where  you
are trying to learn a foreign language, the content
should be interesting, it should be
interesting first of all to you, and if
suddenly at some point you lose
interest because you are reading, it does not matter
, you can always put this text
aside, go to something new and continue
further than  the longer you maintain an
interest in what you are studying, the easier
it will be for you to learn a language in and  toge, well
, somehow sagra in a nutshell, I thought
maybe then the rest will go through I
will complete yes I downloaded the link 2000
last summer you don’t remember me as a husband
yes but I couldn’t use it on my
own, that is, there was
no  - there was no understanding of the direction, I was
waiting to start reading, but it did
n’t lead to anything, and only when I
started these courses from the bones, which
almost step by step takes us through the
necessary steps and understanding how
to communicate with this program and that
perhaps a skill has appeared  and
it is the desire that is very interesting for me that you
can trace your development
because it's all in numbers and it
's visible yes it's when you move
forward and I have a little bit about my life in
it quite a bit at the moment
and therefore I decided that when
there is time  when I read, I listen, that is,
but
I still haven’t been able to create a ritual for some morning and evening,
but still when I have 15 2 and on
and very often dedicate  all now I
sit down at my computer and what am
I listening to this is how you steve also told me
on the way
when I walk to the relationship sometimes I just
sit down and listen very often on household
chores when I clean up or something
like that
when we found yes
this conversation  the ritual began
to change a little bit because it was necessary to
look for some topic and the
lessons take an hour and therefore
listen to the mistakes and now I am in a phase where
I am trying to find some kind of rhythm again for us,
but I am very very inspired by the
program itself, this is what then the husband
I decided to use this particular program
because it feasts on my philosophy of
how to learn languages ​​how I learned
English and so thank you very much
come and thank you Steve thank you
very much Steve I also like this program very much
I started studying the bone system
with this program since September  you
can’t hear it well, therefore, the bone explained everything very clearly,
therefore, in principle,
it was easy right away, it was easy to immediately
master this program  and learn
new skills how to learn to learn languages ​​here is
a very convenient program, that is,
technically very cool that you can
click on an unfamiliar word to immediately
get a translation and, again, what you
even said that it’s possible it’s like a game
like that, that is, you can kind of have such
motivation as much as you  I learned the words, that is
, somehow, but it works so psychologically
that it motivates me to go further, Kostya
suggested the first book, in my opinion, it was
for catchers, look and then somehow further
with the next book, it’s getting easier and easier
, now it’s already 6 for now I have such books
they don’t read very difficult, but I
remember that when we were just starting
bones, we used to say we read everything there,
we could learn
new ones a day there 10 links given 10 words and the bones
say well, now I’m already taking into account 30-40 a
day  muddy, I thought how this is possible, but
now when the more you learn, the
more you read,
then these words themselves appear in
your head from somewhere and that is, in reality, now 30-40
you still remember the word  nila kostya how I
say it, that is, it’s easier and easier to
remember the words and it’s easier, as it were, the language
begins to appear, and I still
tried to do what the ritual is called,
yes, that is, I try to read
when I get it when it’s intensive
work maybe in the evening now when
quarantine is in  during the day and
then I even said there household chores,
here is the preparation there, to cook something and
listen to it, it’s generally just time
flies by unnoticed its benefits, that
is, in principle, we all probably what I
think that many people don’t know much about
reading and  listening to them and most
people think that the need to have
learning is not so necessary for the brain to
get used to language language language and for this you do not
need to learn to read and listen and
start talking but I think that the
program is an ideal situation
because so many people start glinka  we
don't know how to use them and
it's very easy to lose motivation or
just don't understand and so I
think  iwali is a
very good way
i if we have become more people like
konstantin bones on there will be many many of
our members people very very well i
also i wanted to answer the question of the stage
she say in english oh what not
to write very well and of course i always think
in order to speak well, one must speak, but one
must learn and potential through listening for
four days and the same in the case of
writing, one must read a lot, one must
increase the level of words, the reserve must
improve the level, say, the familiarity of the
physics visa, and then one must
write a lot a lot, this is a matter of time and
therefore continue importing  well, it’s necessary
that and teaches the ability to write you need to write a
lot you need to look for a formula
for business there is a lot on the Internet
and then write the same Konstantin from
sergey
who I know and he said and
will show better show the rays how you
use the centuries for everyone you worked
with my styles and approach I don’t know what
you think I need to show I don’t know
attention well I’m sorry for interrupting it
seems to me  that this is a great idea I
personally was very interested to see
how the guys what they do but I don’t believe
that we have enough time this time
maybe if it’s interesting for the audience and
we can meet again on after
again and devote specifically to this
demonstration maybe guys a little
get ready they will put things in order but I
would like to answer his second
question where he talks
about yellow words and how how to study
because I tried to
use cards with me and it’s
just
perfect I kind of had the feeling that well,
that’s exactly how  at school there you need to
cram something and I don’t remember anything and I’ll
never succeed in anything and so on,
but when I read and when I listen, it doesn’t
happen very much, this link in my mind
there is a real connection between
what you read and
and  you listen and the cards are
completely unsuitable for me, that is, I see
yellow words, I translate them from the back, from the back,
as I also insert some information on the side of the
gram  matic from time to
time if I want to if I want to
and then gradually just encountering
these words here you study them like as
Sasha said yes, that is, for me the
cards were not mine
but this is a good option for some
I especially think in the future I don’t know
in a week  -two 3rd I will probably deal
with the size
because I highlight phrases that I
would like to know to remember which I
find useful in daily speech and so
on and
I pay attention to them but I must
say my approach is very similar to
something I said  i'm george words and i don't
use card very much when i
start yes i will every time i
start a new page
but maybe i will a little bit later
very very rarely most of all i read of
course i most of all i listen but when
i read i very often  I will blow this
word of this river because I don’t know most of the yellow
words, it’s only me, it’s 100
words, it means I saw this word somewhere, that’s
basta, I don’t know that I know this word and
then  every time i see it but i
see it i see
it helps me a little bit
better to understand or
accumulate words yes and i would and sometimes i will
change the status from 1 to 2 mints and
again to two or
sometimes one and then i don’t know and then  2
ipad
is a way to say and if i don't know the
meaning i'm from a dictionary
i won't waste time to
do it remember how it is during the day it's
only
x later and eventually when i start
for example in arabic or persian all the
pages just
got more and more yellow and  then it
means I don't know how why in
what way well I know more more
words and yes not through cards it's only
after four and I play for peugeot you
word sometimes
out of 100 thousand 1 out of 3 start out of 2
but he stopspies again 2 little by
little  it became less on mine
and like the following context there is less
and less copper and the number of percent
know she is not
unfamiliar unfamiliar words words less
and less became 30 percent then 20
percent then 15 10 15 these are very
good suites decline because there you
will see a new one but it's not too
difficult to pour percent unfamiliar words
it's too hard but 15 10 15 this I don't
know evgeny if this answers
your question
I often eat your
perast they jassa can
if they are well heard  about these
yellow words, I would like to say that it also
went well costa dorada costa is
audible well yes about the yellow words
from my experience I can say that I am
about the cards yes again when you
yellow words appear I roughly speaking I
look at him at this  the words yes and I
don't know it that I don't know it I make it
yellow I click on it look at the translation this
I call touch when I go to the
next sentence I already forget about
this sentence and about this word
maybe I'll see you on the next page
maybe  be taken alive to another book and
then I will touch it again for each
word you need a different amount of touch
not for some 5 touches are enough
this time click on it and look
for some you need 45 to some 105
you never know how much you need
but you don't worry about just you know
that when you need it you look at it
no more you need to look at the translation to
know it and at that moment you make
it colorless that's all  you can not
use the cards too much and
just read something for your pleasure,
but you see that the yellow words gradually
gradually to said steve and it
becomes less and less, more and more
traveler,
I can’t just say a word on my own,
given that I just
use the cards until  until now, but I
never have them, yes, no matter how funny it
sounds, I never consider them as an
option for some kind of exam for me, it’s
more like a
button accordion, you’re entertainment, that is, roughly speaking,
I look at the word, I have some kind of
association with it, I’m trying to remember  its
meaning and then I open
this card in any grief and look at the right thought
its wrong and if you guessed it ok it's
great if you didn't guess well on the trail
it will work out maybe if there is a
next time i.e. every day i
never force myself to work with
cards specially there for some
amount of time it happens to me
well automatically get some
texts
[music]
when i read american gods
gameman yes  he has a very beautiful language
and at the same time he uses a fairly
large number of words that I, in
principle, have not seen anywhere before
,
and here, of course, the cards came in
very handy because the words are beautiful,
they are well varied in a variety of colloquial
speech and I really wanted to remember them here too
Of course, I forced myself to work with them a little,
but most of the time I
use the cards exactly as
entertainment, that is, as some kind of even
certain rest from some kind of
work, yes, if it is during the day I
work in the office, I have some tasks
I need to switch  and opening the
cards and devoting 10 minutes to new fats
just switching the brain from one task to
another is  in principle, it’s good to work and
at one time with bones, this is a very good
advice to mark in yellow not specific
individual words, but to use phrases
that go with these words, and this
option works very well
for beginners, of course, because those phrases
that I learned at the very beginning to some
ready-  then the patornas that can be
used with one turn of speech,
they are stuck in my head, well, that’s
so firmly, that is, even if I
forget
50 percent of English words, then
it’s these patterns that were learned at the very
beginning, they will still remain and in any
situation they pop up
and, as it were  I didn’t worry, for example, in
some meetings and they pop up on their own,
I don’t even force myself to
specifically remember the words, well, I
wanted to say, I don’t want to say, I
never use the card, for example,
when I studied Russian, I used it very often
, for example  for us it is very
difficult and for you to
focus many many examples
before examples for example the interface I
use  this one and then on the sex of his
cable i can see
there is if i want examples in space i
used to concentrate and in
case it is grammatically
problems like which is still
very difficult for me therefore and and and another
example this is a lot of languages ​​very useful
and downloaded for example  until be released
which actually i am very much and if i
search in russian or girlfriends language
starts with f and there will be many form of
the same words and all that we can
see in concentrated form
is a little easier to learn because
through this and
this  look or form,
let's say it is the same words, it's not this
concentration on one context,
sometimes it knocks out yes and on another text and
someone somewhere,
but if I look for words that
start with or or
there I will see it in
concentrated forms, this too  the very
idea and how the use of tikes i think
that if we will
i like to use the card as i said
when i start when i
go on the new page 4 expo already on or
or on the gram  you understand matically I
agree agree with alexey for me
too since the game I don’t make cards
every day but that’s how you
sit at work you have 10 minutes and
you switch 1 time as simple as a
form igor it called cards that
one word and among them  sects
[laughter]
yes, but I also often fail to do them
here friends I wanted to say goodbye to
say thank you again to me with English
starting literally in 5 minutes I
wanted to say thank you
very much Steve thank you very much Kostya and Dasha and Lyosha for
joining us  they did this
program and Kostya helps with all his might in
general I really liked it very much I
have English I always had
English at the same
pre-intermediate level and now it has
only started for four months I’ve started to teach already, well
, somehow change so  thank you very much
and see you again bye
[laugh]
mike told me that there are questions on youtube
i don’t see anything but no matter how many
questions you can answer about what kind of
sport yes i will count marina
asks steve how did you learn russian
hold they are very difficult they are very
difficult to learn for me what system do you have
russians that i hold the difference on
visa and i haven’t studied for me yet if i
will for example when i was in russia yes they
speak every day  -Russian I think
that the entrance has become a little rays
because I listen to how people use the language but
for me the most important thing is to say pepper to
learning languages ​​is understanding and if I
don’t really know exactly there is if it’s not I
don’t know Russian for the dd tool I
I don't know but there are enough words
enough words I can understand
even if I don't know exactly paris
[music]
therefore therefore therefore yes and therefore I 1
I don't know six months I only listen to
read and I start to get used to and then I
read the explanation the question is not
explain it
and know why
there is run why and how to use the
tool series it's not that hard
it's hard it's right to use it and
it's very difficult because even if I
understand what it is
I know  media connections I can explain but I
can't use so everything to use
this right to use
I have to practice I have to talk a lot I didn't
talk about two times a week through attacks
or something I have to say a lot so that
when I listen to people who I listen to
people who  really say
they say I can get used to it a little bit
and that's why paris it's
how difficult it is that I think that now
May's feed has become worse because now I
don't read much listen to him I don't
speak Russian and it has become worse because it's
so and how to handle
speak english and in the pen no alex sneg no
illusions speak very very
fluent english
without arepas i.e. many times no i know
here in canada
stone mighty well alex bowls
no matter we understand them understand because
it doesn't exist according to  in Russian
it will run itself, it exists
in English, so I think that I can
if I live in Russia and Ukraine for
several months, but the Duce will be there and
now I am not using  I use pens and that’s why it
got worse and I think it’s a matter of
time
[laugh]
we also speak English or
Russian translate what
language you are in
[music]
like you like music
they
hurry
kharkov
source new session  colposcopy
[music]
need to
yana
[music]
rise blass
I can add on my own in Russian in
Russian I had a break when I
switched to Swedish
I had quite a big break in
English maybe  three, maybe
even four months when I don’t do anything at all,
that is, I didn’t read, I didn’t listen
periodically, maybe I watched
some TV shows and my own, somehow I
didn’t worry about the language, and then there was a
situation when we arrived friends from the
states a girl from Ukraine
an American boy from Cincinnati for a guy and
now I had a complete immersion in
English literally in one day
because I had to communicate with guests
and even after probably 1 hour of
talking while we were driving  Ali from the airport in the
car all these skills, they
returned almost instantly, that
is, there was some moment there was a plug, yes, that
is, when we tried to remember something,
and then she opened the window,
and then the words themselves popped
up then  yes, reread the month, there
may not be a very big break before
learning the language, but everything recovered quickly enough,
but, as Steve said, of course, by the end of the
first day, I had the feeling that the
boss ran across 10 wagons of cement,
because the whole day to communicate in another
language is but  especially not having such
experience, but having hour-long classes with
teachers and then I have to
talk all day, it was certainly
hard, but by the end of the first week, in
general, I got used to this load and by the end of the
second, I even somehow felt sad
when the guys say, well, I'm on  soul i'm
so used to english i didn't
even want to switch not
friends i'm sorry i have
to leave too thanks to steve yes for such
a o  in general, a powerful study order
thanks to Kostya who introduced me to this
resource and thanks guys
today I hope we will see you again
[music]
impulses and box a5
abbott
[music]
iphone 11
fisherman people
[applause]
current
[  music]
like
became a folding